[Music]
all right let's
be a let's be a room full of guys and
talk about how we like our women's
faces yeah yeah what's your ideal like
shape
with the lips shut right
[Laughter]
hey where's the glue where's the sticky
glue
real quick very true all right so there
is a
uh i guess uh a consensus that uh small
oval shaped faces
and a well-defined v point chin is the
ideal oval huh yeah oval shape what
other shapes are there
like this right square yeah like so a
longer a longer face i guess
you know that makes sense it's like like
the model look right i don't like when
they when they give characteristics like
that like
what's your favorite face and stuff like
and they they blow without glue on this
yeah like when they [ __ ] a
[Laughter]
freeze the best is that supposed to turn
people on when they're like
surprised like if that turns you on i
don't know what to tell you dude it
doesn't turn you on
no it turns me on i think it turns
truckers on oh
i think that's the that's the whole
thing gotcha i never wanted to [ __ ] a
inner tube
yeah bro like what's it made out of it
doesn't look the soft
you know like yeah yeah imagine blowing
it up first though
you have to blow it first
so weird because whenever you blow
something up by hand like by with your
mouth just your mouth it takes
like it takes some time yeah i mean
it takes some effort you know what i
mean so imagine how long it takes to
blow up a [ __ ] i'm sure people are
buying
blow up dolls alongside with like a air
pump
yeah you would imagine yeah right right
next to the
integrity vending machine
all the chicks that i find hot i don't
know if there's like a common thing
yeah dude you're no one's looking at the
shape of their head and
i think that's kind of weird like when
you just like if that's what you're
looking at true
we don't know why we like it how about
that yeah yeah if you're pretty you're
pretty you know what i mean
like i don't like the whole like this is
very specific features i feel like
that's a very serial killer not the
science to it like being in like
they're symmetry right or like the
fibonacci sequence like there is some
sort of perfect ratio
that we are we all like or something but
i'm not measuring that i'm not i'm not
taking it isn't it subjective
too yeah i think it's i mean for for me
it's super subjective
but according to this article a lot of
asian
uh countries their beauty standard seems
to be in the whole small
oval-shaped face with well-defined and
pointy v-line chin
and i thought they like small faces like
there right yeah yeah they do like
like they look like um [ __ ] jack ma
[ __ ] and the face is really small yeah
jack molly is every chick out there is
trying to be jack ma right now
he's got sex appeal dude the guy's hot
yeah
well in asia they're now uh they came
out with the new uh
product and uh
yeah dude [ __ ] that well you only need
to use it for 10 minutes at a time and
it vibrates your face
but uh what is that does that really
work though i bet that doesn't work
face vibrator of course it works
that that is exactly what this is
actually what
oh i get it now
i get it call me jack ma dude
yeah so this is uh selling for about 200
bucks
200. oh like 200 yeah us
and it vibrates your [ __ ] face i
wonder what the model was thinking
activate she's sucking dick yeah no
she's not thinking that's the guy that
designed it like how do i get all women
to suck on dick
yeah where did you get that though like
to build a skill you know
he just designed it like a dildo i also
use that for her [ __ ] too
probably i don't know what it looks like
on the on the other end bro
go away go back go back the [ __ ]
little markings y'all like
it's vibrating your face i swear to god
that i feel like
some of these companies make vibrators
for women
who are too ashamed to buy a dildo
so they mark it in a different way yeah
and then but they
they're gonna [ __ ] go oh marketing
yeah i want to know how what what what
goes inside
her her mouth like a steel billboard
like this on the side of a freeway
[Laughter]
and shape her face mom's driving with
her kid and she's like oh god
god damn it or mom's driving with with
her kid and she has one in her mouth
hey 10 minutes a day dude
but yeah so yeah so this is the before
and after yeah i don't know i don't know
what's on the other side
but before and after i don't see any
difference dude oh the chin the chin's
pointier
you know what this is a little rounder
they just move the camera up a little
bit that's all they
[ __ ] did oh no dude i don't believe
chinese chinese ads do this is [ __ ]
too much fake [ __ ]
science in asia is pretty crazy though
the amount of bro science and any
product being sold is insane you have to
trust
before and after photos though they're
all [ __ ] i love before and after phone i
trust those it's a clinical study
i can see with my eyes yeah
so yeah what does this say what do they
or does anyone know how to read this
oh wait that's what it looks like oh no
no oh yeah that's it
that's it okay so that's what's in her
mouth
something something something something
face machine
um this can't be good for your teeth yo
oh and it helps sharpen your essence yes
that's where you bite down on it
does it help sharpen your chin probably
i can only read like every other word
okay you know i think chewing gum would
probably
solve a lot of oh it says every day use
three minutes
three minutes yeah three minutes of that
every day is not gonna get you a [ __ ]
sharper jaw yo
or maybe just sucking dick for three
minutes a day what could that was
probably hey
come on he's back he's back
you ever seen it you ever seen that
jazzer size there's like oh
where you put and you start chewing on
it i feel like that makes more sense
than [ __ ] this
it's just like a giant ball you put your
mouth it's a gag yeah yeah it's a baldy
gag
it's like a rubber thing but you like
chew it you're working your muscles
so it's like that old school boxer thing
where they chew extra gum or a piece of
tire but they don't get knocked out
because there's actual work being done
but i think a lot of these like
contraptions
it's how do i not do any work and see
what i can do yeah this was like when
you used to see all those info
infomercials for like the ab rollers and
stuff yeah which kind of made sense
because like all right you still working
out and then afterwards people get more
lazy so they're like put this [ __ ]
electro
pad on your thing and just sit there at
work
don't do anything i like shake weight
too shake weights
shake weight makes way more sense of
this now they're they're really
promoting like
that that machine where they put the
electric stimulation
on their stomach and like they're
charging so much money to go to like
a place and actually do it for sessions
really
so crazy who believes this [ __ ] a lot of
people like like uh
there was a influence of the guy she got
in some trouble for promoting this
no [ __ ] for and she was like i think
she's like jake paul's like girlfriend
or something
i like the um the the thing that you
stick and it gives you shocks for
massages
like you know those pads that you see
the stimulators like which is the same
thing that gives you abs apparently yeah
but it doesn't but but when it
stimulates your muscles and
after you take it out the soreness feels
more relaxed i don't know
i don't know the science behind it the
stem machine yeah but i don't think it
makes me buffer
no it doesn't grow it contracts your
muscles for you though right
like it's that thing that where it makes
your muscles move on its own yeah it's
like
clear i guess i guess for like the level
of effort that you put in
it's effective exactly like for your
muscles to be like contracting
with you not doing [ __ ] that's pretty
good yeah yeah yeah
but just because your muscles contract
doesn't mean that they're gonna give
growth or whatever you're trying to look
for so that's that's what the problem
get one and then the entire jk news
sessions from now on i'm gonna sit here
and just constantly do it and then we'll
see
can you turn that off it's interfering
with the equipment
the [ __ ] is that noise fine then i'll
put this in here
yeah they're saying this thing uh
vibrates up to 880 times per minute
high frequency vibrations somehow
stimulate the facial muscles
and reshape your face this is your video
do you think any young people do this
[ __ ] because i feel like it's all old
asian ladies that buy these kind of
weird things
that's so true somebody goes super
hammer like shin is like this
so i do this for three hours a day yeah
someone's gonna take no no one's gonna
do it just for three
nobody who's already who's already hot
is gonna do it how about that that's
true
true that's very true or like the
inventor that like had to go through
like 74 prototypes to get this one done
like their chin's got to be just like
phenomenal
fine point it's like so v-shaped that it
like goes back the other way
in terms of an hourglass hourglass
a lot of attraction has to do with um
good genetics and like
good person to have kids with right like
when you look at their body
or fashioned way of things yeah that was
always hips yeah
the bear bare children right yeah so the
jaw must be something like
this [ __ ] can chew mm-hmm i want babies
that can chew
she's not gonna choke maybe give her a
tough piece of steak and just see how
well she chews it
you know just let's get tested i mean do
you guys think like a pretty face is
like luck of the draw
you know what i mean because i say in
luck of the job because like
when you get born you didn't get to
choose your mate to create you know you
didn't choose your parents
right you know what i mean so when
you're born and you like become
a pretty or beautiful person it's like
man
lucky person there i think everything's
luck on the draw like your parents could
be dumb as [ __ ] your parents could be
super smart you could be like uh like
steve jobs like he was adopted
but apparently his biological parents
were a genius
because he has like the the potential
but then his actual
foster parents knew how to raise him to
be a genius i think all of it's like
luck of the draw the reason be a little
[ __ ] genius apparently
some of that is like environment driven
yeah but like the idea of like a pretty
face
yeah you know what i mean yeah but have
you seen
it's also maintenance too have you seen
like
these girls and their youth they're
they're they're awesome
strippers and then before you know it
they're 50 and they're
super overweight and they look like what
the [ __ ] what happened to you lady
or even the finest chicks in junior high
yeah i remember in high school because i
went somebody to change so many schools
already i'm i wonder what she's up to
and i look her up and i'm like what the
[ __ ] yeah i'm like damn
what happened exactly maintenance
should have dmed like hey what happened
what happened
what do you mean what happened oh pretty
what happened hello comma what happened
like step by step you were given a gift
and you [ __ ]
you squandered it the other way around
is really fun though like the she's all
that right yeah
like braces glasses high school you're
like
oh [ __ ] yeah she just got contacts and
i'll just all of a sudden she's so fine
[Laughter]
eyes are up here buddy yeah you're like
all right relax that actually did happen
though because
i remember being that age and then you
you don't see someone over the summer
and then
they have huge tits all of a sudden
you're like what the [ __ ] is going on in
your house
what did you eat what are you what are
they feeding program are you watching
there's a vibrator at the chest
[Music]
you